je participerai dans la reconstruction
du parti socialiste avec un certain
nombre de mes amis à faire en sorte que
le parti socialiste ne soit pas dans
l'opposition frontale en faisant
communiquer sur communiqué contre tous
mais en étant plutôt vigilant parce
qu'il faut quand la recrue oui parce
qu'il faut que la france réussisse
d'accord et il faut que macro réussi ce
congrès par rapport à lui mais donc moi
je suis candidat oui j'ai pris position
vous convient non non je pense moi la
ligne de position celle du parti je n'ai
rien à redire mais pour le prochain
congrès je pense que le parti socialiste
doit pas être dans l'opposition totale
mais doit être plus tôt dans la campagne
mango vigilant dans et des choses qui
vont pas et des choses qui vont
tranquillement parce que quand on passe
son temps à s'opposer
eh bien on a du mal à prêt à proposer et
les socialistes contrairement à d'autres
contrairement à d'autres partis
d'extrême gauche ou autres ne sont pas
là pour être dans la rue ne sont pas là
pour être contre tous sont là pour
accéder à nouveau pouvoir un jour donc à
avoir un projet politique fort qui peut
rassembler une majorité